the d-backs and the miami marlins the
second of a four-game
series and your starting pitcher for the
diamondbacks the lefty madison bumgarner
unbeaten in his last four starts last
week in miami he gave up a lead off home
run
and then retired the next 17 marlins he
faced
speaking of scary hitters jesusakilar
rips one in a line
over the third baseman extra bases into
the left field corner
so aguilar stays red hot he'll jog into
second base with the one out double here
in the first watch him climb
now baumgardner misses way way
higher in the zone than he wanted to be
carson kelly gave him a target low and
in
now garrett cooper with a man at second
one out and see if the marlins can
strike first here tonight
pitch swing and a miss he strike him out
cut in on him and he didn't get it
and bumgarner's got his first strikeout
two down adam duvall
aguilar down there at second base with
two outs and in his last two games has
struck out five times
now drifting back into fair territory
and that's the end of the top of the
first
eighth start this year and number 50 in
his career era sits at
204 but it has been minuscule
his last four starts pablo the free pass
to pavon smith he's at first base carson
kelly comes up
the 01 is cracking the ground back up
the middle near second base
up with it birdie to rojas for one back
to first double play and that'll erase
the lead-off walk
so two outs and that'll bring up cabrera
he'll bend left-handed
high fly ball it backs up cooper in
right field he's still backing up and
he's
off the top of the wall that's
a double for cabrera he just missed a
home run
looks like it might come down in
cooper's glove it was hit so high in the
air
that it came down right on top of the
wallet
anderson 220 a couple of home runs
anderson has an eight-game
active hitting streak against the
d-backs
swings and misses and he's done
strikeout number two for bob garner and
one out here in the second lewis prince
in the center field of the year and a
swing of the miss he strike him out
three strikeouts two in a row to start
this second inning three on the left
side
against christian walker lopez ahead oh
and two
and the fastball up his first strikeout
tonight went away
well he's got some real life on his
fastball tonight
farm side run explode to the inside
upper corner of the strike
zone mccombett's got his average just
about to 200
hasn't hombered yet high fly ball
down the line in left nick ahmed
gives the diamondbacks the lead that's
the first of the air for nick and it's
one nothing
well you could just see it coming with
mixed swings over the last several days
especially on pitches
up in the zone that's what he got right
there no
doubter to left field so now the pitcher
who gave up the home on pablo lopez
leads off the marlins third
[Applause]
all strike three by chad fairchild on
the curve ball that strikeout number
four
through the first nine batters for
madison buckyard here high breaking ball
that time they get
the call from chad fairchild behind the
plate rojas in the lead off spot
round it out to start off the ball game
right there with a 93 mile an hour
fastball he
rings up rojas strikeout number five for
madison
he must have thought it was gonna be a
cutter because he's thrown so many
cutters in there
this one did just a four-seam fastball
here's akilar who doubled in the first
inning two outs nobody on marlins down
one nothing top of the third
aguilar out toward left and that's off
the base of the wall
peralta fields fires in and
aguilar into second he keeps that toe on
the bag
twinkle toes into second with his second
double tonight off
of matt bump now aggie heating up again
on the road
adam duvall leads off the fourth against
madison bumgarner
center field pavon smith backing up near
the warning track still backing up and
he's got it
one pitch one out in the fourth for man
anderson struck out his first time
moving two on brian anderson the marlins
third base swing on a miss their
strikeout number six
second time he's got anderson back to
the curveball that time it
to have a lot more sweep on that
curveball tonight than he's had
all year long miss walker bats with the
base is empty
strike out first chops it the other way
fair down the line
and cooper's going to run all the way
into the corner to get that
walker is thinking three
christian walkers got a triple we talked
about that at the top of the show since
2014
only coors field has seen more triples
than this ballpark has and walker
gets his first of the year there are two
outs trying to leave that second
diamondbacks run
at third swing and a miss pablo got the
strikeout
to escape the inning for lopez that's
his third k in the game
josh rojas flied out his first time up
he bats eight tonight
3-1 to rojas punches one the other way
here comes duvall
and that drops in for a hit ahmed's on
the move into third
and josh is at second second and third
nobody out
the batter is bumgarner the infield on
the left side playing back
2-2 is head out to left duvall back it
up
at the warning track and he's got it
here comes ahmed rojas moves up as well
he's safe at third the rbi for mattbaume
and it's two-nothing diamondbacks
and now the banner is paving smith the
infield comes in
haven belts it into right here comes
rojas three-nothing diamond banks
bases loaded one out john curtis right
here on a relief now for pablo lopez
david peralta has a chance to bust this
thing wide open
swinging the line drive hitting the
right they'll score a couple
in is smith here comes kelly
to third base cabrera it's a two-run
double for the freight train
and it's five nothing diamondbacks much
more aggressive in this at bat finally
gets a slider in the strike zone after
chasing 97
below the knees and just rips it out
there in the right field corner
chance for the struggling eduardo
escobar it was over two
face it for eduardo peralta's home it's
six nothing
three-two count and the pitch on the way
from baumgarten
swag in a miss strikeout number eight
that's a season high for madison
bumgarner back door
cutter right there he's got it all
working tonight i mean we've talked a
lot about the velocity and it certainly
has spiked up a little bit even again
tonight but
his command is what's really set him
apart over the last four starts plus
tonight
eight strikeouts for mad bum his highest
total as a diamondback
brinson is over two with a strikeout and
they pop to first
brenson chases another high heater that
strikeout number nine for manboom
lewis brinson strike zone is about as
big as the state of arizona right now
biggest if you let it go i might swing
at it here's another challenge for
bumgarner
leone who has got two hits against him a
single on a double
deep to center le castro's out there
madball matted again three outs on nine
pitches he's retired nine straight and
13 of the last 14.
two and two that
is down the line birdie on his way to
third
and he might keep going he's getting the
green light from trey hillman
and rbi double for miguel rojas
marlins are on the board here in the
eighth so miggy's at second for
zeus aguilar who's doubled twice tonight
two for three
102 aguilar did he do it again
did he do it again he did it again
another home run for jesus aguilar
this guy is unreal eight home runs
on the last two road trips and the
marlins are down
six to three chris davinski the new
pitcher for the diamondbacks
now a three run game here in the eighth
inning cooper hits one deep to right
field backs up rojas has got it
josh in right times his leap perfectly
as he gets back to that warning track
spins around what a play seven three
ball game first and third kelly tonight
has watched scored and singled
carson belts that just beyond the reach
of anderson and down the line
van meter makes it eight to three now
you got cabrera at the plate
cabrera hits a deep fly ball right field
and it's gone his fourth hit tonight
and it's 11-3 and the two-one pitch
swinging a ground ball to first smith's
got it steps on the bag ball game over
diamondbacks won it 11-3